foreign
thank you so much for inviting us to
your home here in Kampala in Uganda for
this 10 women conversation I really
appreciate that it's so much nicer to be
in somebody's home having a conversation
so let's start with uh what prompted you
or what what brought you to become a
climate activist to become aware of the
climate issue from from the beginning
you must have been very young because
you're still very young
uh my journey started in 2018 that is
when I started reading about the
challenges that the people in my country
Uganda were facing and at that point I
found out that climate change was one of
those challenges and I remember in
school studying about climate change in
geography class it never made me realize
that it was actually an emergency or
something that was happening at that
time it was really surprised to find
that it is the greatest trait facing the
lives of so many people what was it in
2018 that kind of prompted you I
remember speaking to one of my uncle's
Charles and asking him if he has seen
any changes from when he was much
younger and right now and he explained
to me that 20 years ago in a specific
place he mentioned in Michiana that they
would expect rains at a specific time
but then he said now 20 years later
he cannot the farmers cannot tell when
the rains would come so he actually said
there's been a change but no one is
talking about it so that really
triggered me to start doing something
about it I didn't know what exactly I
had to do but after seeing Greta turn
back from Sweden strike I was really saw
those photographs of her in front of the
Swedish Parliament yes in 2018 yeah I
saw them too yeah so I was really
inspired by her actions and I decided
that I would start striking as well
however I was quite scared to go to the
street so why am I being scared I think
I just I've always been nervous to face
people so many people a little bit shy a
[ __ ] yes yeah but um I tend to manage
it I should say you were in Davos with
Greta tomberg and some other well-known
climate activists and there was a photo
taken I think of five of you and the
other four were white women why do young
women know you were all very young and
you were cut how's the photograph yes uh
you could have just you know accepted
that but you didn't tell us about a why
you know how you felt and then why you
decided to react to the way you did and
what you did guess uh when I first saw
the photograph I was of course really
frustrated because I remember one of the
messages I really emphasized that the
press conference was the need to listen
to the voices you know of different
activists of course
exactly so it was quite disappointing to
see and also frustrating for me but also
at that point I just wanted to ask why I
had been removed from the picture and
that's exactly what I did I asked why
yeah and that really gave me the
opportunity to talk about you know some
of the intersections of climate change
for example with racial Justice and talk
about this big long word and that we use
intersectionality
yeah uh so when when we talk about
intersectionality it's just something
that explains that climate change is not
just on its own climate change is more
than whether it's more than statistics
it's about the people and when we bring
in the composition of intersectionality
it makes us talk about you know things
like poverty or education it makes us
talk about racial Justice in our fight
for you know climate Justice yes
um and
you
you know you've been the face on Time
Magazine you you you have reached very
high visibility as a voice for Africa
how has that been how how has that
Journey for you been how have you felt
internally have you managed to cope with
you know being well known presumably
you've got lots of social media messages
lots of everything and maybe some of
them are negative how do you cope yeah
um well I want to first of all say that
you know I'm not the voice of Africa and
yeah
um
yes
and the the publicity or the fame if I
should say that comes with that it can
be both positive and also negative and
negative it can be you know the people
who will say that what you're doing is
not real or you're exaggerating the
climate crisis or people who will tell
you your you know a young woman she can
get married instead of standing on the
street so it comes with all that but one
thing I've realized that you know the
one percent is the negativity but the 99
it's the support from different you know
parts of the world so I made sure that I
look at the support from the different
people and do you take steps to make
sure that your own self-care is
um you know going well that that you've
got to balance in what you're doing yes
um
apart from activism I I do many other
things in my own personal life uh one
like you've talked about self-care I
really love to rest and many times for
me rest is actual sleep
yes so I I really love to get good sleep
and actually everyone here at home knows
that and also I love getting involved in
church activities yes yes I know you've
talked about uh
capitalism as being part of a problem in
degrading land and degrading you know
the extracting and degrading Etc what
kind of structures would you like to see
in a broad sense what kind of world
would you like to see yes
um I would like to see a kind of world
that respects people but also respects
the planet as well and it's important to
note that we are in a system that has
created the climate crisis and many
other challenges that people are facing
and when we demand for system change we
mean that the system actually has to
change we cannot solve you know the
problems that are happening right now
with the very system that created them
so we need something new something that
will ensure that people are protected
and the planet is protected as well when
it when it comes to consumption I think
it's a place of governments helping to
make cities more sustainable for people
because it could be transportation for
example when you're in a country within
Europe you can very easily use the train
to get to so many places to even go
through and get I mean get to another
country which may be difficult in in
some places or in some countries so I
think it's really a place of making our
cities and our countries more
sustainable so that people can live more
sustainably when it comes to you know
food when it comes to Transportation
when it comes to clothing itself you
know the issue of population it is not
the problem in our fight for the climate
crisis I agree because it's important to
know that you know while Africa has a
huge population it is responsible for
less than four percent of the global
emissions and a family of maybe 10 in
Uganda will emit way less than a family
of four in a country within Europe so
it's really a place of understanding who
has caused this crisis and what needs to
be done to make people live more
sustainably
and you've turned the focus which I want
to do on your continent
um
Africa
there are so many crises at the moment
uh there is you know a food crisis a
fuel crisis there was the covet crisis
and a lack of Equitable access to
vaccines and behind that and there all
the time and much earlier has been the
climate crisis so how do you want the
conference that we're going to see the
African conference in Egypt in November
cop 27
how do you see the priorities what do
you want to see happen but when it comes
to loss and damage the climate crisis is
pushing so many communities Beyond
adaptation when you know a family loses
a family member you can adapt to a loss
of like you know you've talked about the
food crisis for example in the Horn of
Africa that has left more than 20
million people with no access to food
you can't adapt to starvation you know
when uh islands are being washed When
being submerged by flooding or by the
rising sea levels it's evident that you
can adapt to Lost Islands or to sinking
coastlines so this is where Lawson
damage comes in yeah one of the things
about development is you know
industrialized countries built their
economies on fossil fuel and African
countries have wanted to go as green as
possible but they haven't got the
investment and support and some
countries want to go more into the gas
they found or the coal they've they've
they've found particular gas more
recently and pipelines you've written
about this you feel very strongly about
this as a young African climate activist
tell us more
yes there is a very big challenge that
so many African nations are facing right
now there is a pressure to transition to
renewable energy there's a pressure to
lift people you know out of energy
poverty but then there is no climate
Finance to do that so what is happening
is that fossil fuel companies are coming
with all you know these deals for the
gas or for for the oil in the different
countries because they're finding it
harder in other regions exactly but then
if the finance the climate finance that
is very much needed by these nations is
delayed they are being pressured to lift
their communities out of energy poverty
so you know that that's what makes the
climate crisis more than weather so now
there is an issue of energy poverty and
we know that millions of people across
Africa have no access to electricity so
that's why the demands of climate
Finance are very clear we need the money
to help communities those that are on
the front lines to help people to lift
people out of energy poverty but in a
more cleaner way while transitioning to
renewable if you make any exception for
you know
um the possibility of clean cooking gas
as a temporary and just transition to
help as one of the solutions because
there are other solutions to clean
cooking or getting you know electricity
into homes I'm just wondering I mean are
you of the view that there's no room at
all or and because many people feel that
developing countries should have some
leeway because the very reason you gave
Africa is such a lower measure and
internationally and yet has real
development needs and I'm not talking
about new infrastructure I'm talking
about getting to people who need clean
cooking or who need electricity in their
home well I think that when it comes to
you know clean cooking and getting
electricity to people still we have to
take the renewable way unfortunately gas
is unsustainable and it can't be very
harmful to so many people I know that
when Comet Finance is made available a
lot of transformation can be made I run
a project that I started in 2019 and it
involves the installation of solar
panels and eco-friendly cookstops in
schools in Uganda I don't have you know
specific climate finance that is coming
in for that project but it's been
different people that are supporting you
know online through agofan and we've
done installations in 31 schools now
they have access to electricity through
solar you know they have access to clean
cooking through eco-friendly cookstops
so I think the solutions are available
we just need political will and money to
be available yeah so you would even say
um you know for uh
you know that you wouldn't even have gas
as a temporary just transition solution
um to help women for example in
particular to get more choices of access
to clean cooking we current with gas I
believe the most sustainable is to help
women so you're very firm yes I I love
you to talk more about the Africa that
could be there if we move more quickly
um what would it mean how do you see
uh for example in Wetlands how do you
see it in in terms of what would change
in cities
um uh what would change I mean yes
there'd be electricity and households
but how else could there be significant
difference in jobs as well as in better
livelihoods
yeah um I'll start by sharing something
I told a friend of mine
um while I was in Europe and we were
going to take the train from one country
to another and I told him that if I had
lots of money right now I would take
this public transportation to my country
Uganda as well so I think those are some
of the things that we could see happen
if things start moving to see that
public transportation is made more
accessible is made more affordable and
also more sustainable for people because
when public transportation is made you
know sustainable and affordable for
people it moves things very fast because
you can easily move from one place to
another but in the most sustainable way
possible so I think that when things
start moving actual money because here
what we are talking about is political
will and making climate Finance
available this is what will enable our
African nations build more sustainable
cities yeah you mentioned the projects
that you're working on in rural schools
and to have solar panels and better cook
stuff
system what other projects that you know
of
um or that you've seen or that you've
heard of particularly
excite you yeah so this project is
really to educate young people about
trees and also to grow these trees with
them so what I've seen with her project
is that she teaches the you know the
students in schools to not only plant
but also grow the trees so much of them
exactly nature them so I think that is
very that is something that I find very
exciting and also here in Uganda I've
seen you know different activists doing
different tree planting projects
especially fruit trees to help the
communities that they're where they're
taking these trees to not only have you
know trees for environmental reasons but
also for food because they are future
sometimes for health as well exactly yes
so there's a those are some of the
things that I have seen here that are
very inspiring yeah I remember being
there in a conversation at Corp 26 and
yeah it was with uh some indigenous
leaders yes and one of the leaders said
that
um usually before they make decisions
they always sit in a community and ask
themselves will this decision be good
for the children yeah and if they say no
there is a possibility that it could
harm the children in this way then that
that immediately would disqualify that
decision so I do agree that there is a
place of choosing the decisions like
making decisions that will ensure that
children are protected or the planet is
protected and also just to add something
in scripture afraid that says you know
I've given you a choice of life and
death so you choose between life and
death so when I bring it to the climate
crisis we have a choice I chose to
either walk into a world that is
beneficial for all of us or a choice
that will take us into the world that
may harm some people earlier but in the
end it will impact everyone so I do
agree that we must make a choice but I
like that wisdom that you shouldn't take
decisions that may impact on wrongly on
future Generations this gets back to
your
oil and gas in Africa yeah you know it
sounds you know short-term
um yeah but it's not actually short term
because putting in that infrastructure
will take some years and by that time
and then we know it's actually adding to
the problem yeah yeah so yeah it's a
kind of
um very very good point to think about
the future impacts of all actions and
the impact particularly on as you say
children and grandchildren yeah yeah
yeah I believe that all life on Earth is
support and I believe that there is an
intersection of interconnection of all
life on the planet and just to really
add on that I in my tribe I am amuganda
by tribe we have different Clans and I
mean then joval Clan it means elephants
so recently I got to learn that you know
one of the reasons for putting the
cleanse was to preserve wildlife
and what happens with the clients it
means if I am in the elf on Clan I can't
eat an elephant I cannot harm or kill an
elephant so it will be the same for
another person who is maybe in a lion
club or under different Clans you find
that there are different kinds of tree
species or plant species or animals or
marine species and in that way that was
the wisdom to preserve the different
animals and the different ones and the
different trees so I do believe that in
a way there is a connection between you
know the different kinds of Life on this
art
um what I wanted to ask you about is the
importance if you think so of
intergenerational conversation so I do
believe that we need an
intergenerational conversation to
address the climate crisis because I am
not the first climate activist in the
whole world and I know that you know the
movement is not the fast movement in the
whole world I know that there have been
people who have been organizing and
mobilizing you know for so many years
demanding for you know climate Justice
or a better environment for all of us I
know that you've been doing incredible
work as well you know for the
environment so I believe I have
something to learn from you and many
other people who started this work way
before I did and I also believe there is
a place for them to learn from me as
well so I think it's a place of Bridging
the different wisdoms of the older
generation and the younger generation to
come up with that one conversation
because you know the fight is not just
for the younger generation the fight is
for everyone so Vanessa how do you see
the increasing climate shocks basically
and impacts impacting on the rights of
people in African countries
yes I will first of all mention
something I remember in school that was
taught about rights so being told that
people have the right to clean air or
people have the right to water or to
housing and these are the very things
that the climate crisis is destroying
when it comes to water sources we know
that for so many people so many
communities when they experience dry
spells they have to you know walk long
distances to look for water and you know
when it comes to housing we know that
many people have lost their homes
because of flooding because of
landslides we've had you know recent
floods in the valley region here in
Uganda and thousands of people were
displaced and their homes were destroyed
so it's really a place of understanding
that the very rights that we were taught
in school you know they are being
affected by the climate crisis many
times women are on the front lines of
the climate crisis and this is because
for many communities women have the
responsibilities of providing food
providing water or something exactly so
when you know crops are drying because
of you know too much heat it's the women
that are on those Farms when the Farms
are destroyed or washed away it's the
women that are impacted they're the ones
working on those Farms when water
sources dry out it's women that have to
walk very long distances for some
communities it's even worse for you know
children especially girls who have to
drop out of school some are forced into
early marriages you know because their
families can't take them to school
anymore and when they get them married
off they expect a bright price that can
help them recover from the climate
impacts so it's really evident in that
the climate crisis disproportionately
affects so many girls and so many women
across Uganda across Africa and across
the world
I wonder if what kind of message you
would give
um you know just at the end of this
conversation a final message of what
action everybody can take
and now I'm not talking about Africa I'm
actually talking more about the worlds
that needs to move more more quickly out
of fossil fuel for example but what
message would you have for
those who are listening to this
conversation yeah um I'll first of all
say that many times you know the climate
crisis seems very complex and many
people want to do something but they
don't know exactly what they can do but
there's so many things that can be done
and we you know we want to we all want
to do everything but it's finding that
thing that will transform something you
know no one is too small to make a
difference and no action is too small to
transform the world it's like we are all
one body and every part of that body has
different actions so it's a place of
finding your part and a lot in the body
and say I would do this that if you are
in law we did an event about law
together yeah so if you're 36 episode 26
so if you are in law you can find your
place in what you're doing that as a
lawyer or as a judge you're going to
support different activists because
we've seen activists take you know
different cases to coach in regards to
climate issues
that if you are a teacher you're going
to use your space as a teacher in school
to teach the students to tell them not
only about what is happening but about
what they can do so it's really a place
of finding your part in the body and
just doing your part because in the end
when we put all the different actions of
the different members of the body we
actually transform the whole world yeah
well Vanessa all I can say is I have
really enjoyed this conversation and I
hope you have yes I have thank you so
much it was a lovely conversation and I
had so much to learn from you